travailler moins pour être plus
productif c'est la solution proposée par
microsoft à ses employés au japon
pendant tout le mois d'août microsoft a
imposé la semaine de travail de quatre
jours à ses 2300 employés à tokyo les
travailleurs korité d'une journée de
congé supplémentaire sans frais chaque
vendredi une anomalie dans un pays où la
culture d'entreprise suggère plutôt de
passer le plus de temps possible au
boulou les microsoft en afrique des
avantages les absences des employés ont
été réduites de 25% mais surtout la
productivité a bondi de 40%
un gain réalisé notamment grâce à des
réunions plus courtes ou virtuel et le
taux de satisfaction des employés a été
propulsé à 91 pourtant avec un tel
succès microsoft répétera maintenant
cette expérience à plusieurs reprises
dans l'année
[Musique]